we could be walking down the hallway he
can become this way not come that way
and i probably started seeing you
starting quarterback
you look down at your phone so guess
what i do i put my head down and we went
right past each other and won't say
[Music]
nothing
you had a long career in the nfl uh-huh
and a lot of people know you for taking
it back to the crib
special teams dude there are very few if
any they were better than you the only
person i could think of is really dante
hall they'll be in that same category
and if you take this insult correct me
if i'm wrong
how do you take that insult is anybody
better than you that's returning not
what i did
i do think there's some good guys out
there some great returners out there
but i don't think anybody that had done
it the way i did people believe return
specialists like brian mitchell and
yourself belong in the hall of fame
well i think brian mitchell and devin
hester should have a space in kent i
think so but
i think they all wait on me first to
make it once i'm in i think
some of the other to get in but to be
fair to myself i do feel like i should
be the first one in
the other question i always had about
your career was why you weren't used
more as a wide receiver
especially in chicago it seemed like
those first couple years that were kind
of easy you
in a similar way that you know guys like
cordell patterson right now right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right right are being
used right
what happened there why didn't you get
more opportunities a wide receiver would
you feel
the real reason behind that was so my
third year was when i
redid a new contract and became the
number one receiver that's the same year
we brought in jay cutler
he's not really a sociable guy
he's not a talker you know what i mean
he picks one or two guys
and he just leashes on him and separates
himself from everybody
as a quarterback like i tell him to this
faith today that to me
my years in the nfl i played 11 years
he's the best
quarterback when it comes to accuracy
power
knowledge of the game the best
quarterback hand down i ever played with
now when it comes to
a leadership the worst the worst
the worst he don't know how to
communicate he don't know how to get a
teammates involved
for me to be like at that time one of
the number one number two or civil like
you supposed to have my back regard so
clearly y'all didn't have the best
relationship
nah i feel like personally the only
person i feel has been cool with
jay cutler is brandon marshall crappy if
i'm wrong it just it feels like every
other person has some sort of story or
some sort of
disagreement or at odds with jay cutler
that's true that you mentioned that so
b marshall voices peeing a lot him and
jay cutler came in together
and denver they were like brothers like
they argued
be marshalled because of my living way
field i'm on the sideline we're in
practice right they doing pre-game
warming up
tossing and throwing the ball jay cutler
be marshall get into it be
martial like i made you you know what i
mean
you want bj all these pro bowl stuff you
got you got this because of me i'm
looking at julie pepper he looking at me
i say listen here we finna make a bet i
say
i bet you jay cutler throw beat marsha
the ball if he throwing the ball you
give me fifty dollars
if he don't want to be moist i'm gonna
give you a hundred dollars
that's how comfy you were that's how
comfortable i said i don't know how to
practice and go he mad at j not j color
for giving them all the whole price what
you walk away from
we stopped betting the bet stopped he
we stopped the bet at 21 passes he threw
it 21 to marshall he threw it 21 passes
to be marshalled
21 straight i looked at the coach like
are you really [ __ ] kidding me
and won't know what to say nothing that
was where it pissed me off 21 times
straight bro that's like a wreck you got
from there
we stopped back he said bro he's going
to give you your game check it out
straight bro what was julius pepper
saying after 21 times are you looking
straight at julia he was just laughing
you
listen they argue like cats and dogs
that's why b marshall give
jay cutler all the praise man go ahead
get the shot in real quick
okay
[Music]
yo i'm justin tuck do me a favor
subscribe to bleacher report
and check out untold stories